Looking at the diagram, you can see that we're achieving the exact same thing as
before but with less repeated code.
The Van and the Cop functions produce the same kinds of objects they always did,
but they're allowing Car function to do most of the work for them first.
But in addition to providing a basis for the Van and the Cop
constructor functions, the Car function is also a full-fledged class itself.
If my code ever needed to make simple Car objects that lack the more
specific Van and Cop methods, then we could just call car directly.
And with that we have completed our refractor to include a super class and
two sub classes.
Interestingly, the car class now looks exactly the way the van class did
before we introduced the whole idea of cops into our program.